Hello, the internet, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo guys, and we're here
at Purdue University in Indiana.
And I'm terrified of where
we're standing right now.
It's quite intimidating isn't it?
You know when you looking
down the barrel of a gun,
this is slightly different.
We're in front of a giant combustion tube.
Yeah, what it's for,
is actually testing flame acceleration,
and deflagration to detonation transition.
But, what we're interested
in, as the Slow Mo guys is,
blowing stuff up, so.
Not really, just like obliterating stuff.
Annihilating stuff,
what's the word you like?
What's the word?
Eviscerate?
Eviscerate, that's the one.
Eviscerate is a good word.
So, we're going to
eviscerate this Mac, and.
Circa 2004.
Something like that .
When did that I-Mac come out?
I don't know.
We've got some retro equipment,
and we're basically going to
put this over here very fast,
and film it in slow motion.
And we're going to send
it back to the 90s,
at 28,000 frames per second.
How fast does it go?
This?
No, how fast does this?
Oh, the flame comes out
about 1,800 meters a second.
So!
God!
Yeah .
I'm going to stand, get the
hell out of the way of it.
I've had enough standing for an afternoon.
Here we have our Mac,
speakers and old school
equipment, you know.
On a nice desk, all from sort
of late 90s to early 2000s.
Here, is the combustion tube.
Look at the state of all these tubes.
Do you wonder if I should twist one?
Don't touch it.
Don't you dare
I don't know what to do with this thing.
It almost looks like it's
some sort of film weapon,
where they're like "oh
I've developed this new".
It's a James Bond, bad
guy weapon for sure.
Absolutely!
Man with the golden gun.
And the Mac's gone.
It's an apple remover.
Yeah .
Okay, so we're going to film
this at 1,000 frames a second
in 4K, on this bad boy.
And when that, inevitably,
isn't slow enough,
we'll cut to this footage,
which is good at 28,500 frames per second.
The V2511, cheers Destine.
And then we've got a
light, that's lighting it.
Because it's a pretty grisly day.
It's blue!
What?
It blew in the beginning
That was like, I didn't
see anything in real time.
It did it, like it went bang,
and the computer was suddenly over there.
Did not think it would be blue.
My table.
It's blown to smithereens.
My table is ruined, I can't
believe my table's ruined.
Should we see how we have
to use the computer now.
Because previously, we had a keyboard,
and we could use the computer.
Now,
and we just,
log on.
No, it's not working.
Well that's 'cause it's not Apple Macs.
Oh yeah, obviously.
Where's the rest of the plastic bits?
Oh, there's some of it.
Oh no, the plastic was just
annihilated everywhere.
Look, there's on the floor
there, some behind the tube.
It's just that we de-shelled the Mac,
and then blasted the screen, face first,
into this wall .
God, oh.
Do you want a CD drive, I've got one here?
That's good.
That's the motherboard.
Oh, now, now, that's
pretty much the only way
to get into a Mac.
Is to use.
Do you want to upgrade your ram?
We've turned it into an I'm.
I'm, oh this is all right then.
Oh, nope.
Nope, it's not there.
It's the illusion of being all right.
So the keyboard is in one piece.
It didn't blow any of the keys out.
Oh, yeah, it did, space bar.
You always lose the space bar.
Space bar's gone to space.
Oh and there's the ah, the electronics
of the keyboard.
Oh yeah, the electronic part yeah, cool.
So the processes, the pressy tech.
Got your metal in there.
Look at this.
Nothing else up there.
Oh look, some of this.
Oh, the squidgy.
Oh yeah, the satisfying part.
Oh these feel great.
Yeah, a little wet though, aren't they?
A bit moist?
Ah, they feel good.
Although, hang on.
Speaking of moist.
I think my favorite part of that,
is just how, just so quickly,
there was just blue flame engulfing it,
then there was orange flame,
and then the Mac hadn't
even moved at this point.
Yeah, the explosion was pretty much done.
And the Mac was maybe an
inch from where it started.
Probably, about an inch.
With the momentum to carry
it all the way to the wall.
It's just like a catapult, amazing.
That's quality.
I'm even more scared of
standing next to this thing now.
I think we should get one of these.
Can you imagine what we could do?
It would be nice.
Imagine what we could do
to the neighbor's shed.
Impress the girls.
With that?
Yeah!
Looking like a cannon?
Huge thanks to Purdue
University, in Indiana,
for helping us make this video.
And flying us out here
to film with this beast.
Hopefully one day we can come back
and blow up some more stuff with it.
Oh, I can think of plenty of things.
Me too, I got a list.
I'm making a list right now.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter.
Subscribe to the Slow Mo guys,
we've got a second channel.
I always do that when
I say second channel,
I just assume I'll put the thing there.
Right there on you.
You typing up some, you typing notes?
This would be a good idea
for like a futuristic keyboard.
You don't think?
I think that's a step backwards.
Oh, come on.
It's satisfying with the buttons.
Back to physical buttons?
Yeah but, they're just so much better.
Hopefully you enjoyed that,
we'll see you in the next one.